um evening everyone
um look obviously it's been turbulent
time uh for the government but I think
the most important thing is to make sure
that people in this country uh know that
they've got security uh and that's why
it's a great honor to be appointed as
Home Secretary today I'm looking forward
to uh getting stuck into the role and
providing the the sort of security that
the British people need regardless of
what's Happening uh otherwise in in
Westminster so I'm looking forward to
getting on with the job and thank you
for coming out this evening says the
government's broken key pledges has it
on particularly on migration well you'll
forgive me I'm literally you know 10
minutes into the job so I'll I'll
refrain for commenting on the specifics
of of the of this role for the second
but I mean look I accept that the
government has obviously had a very
difficult period as Jeremy Hunt said
when he was appointed on on Friday uh
that nonetheless means it's doubly
important to ensure that we are doing
absolutely everything to in in the basic
areas of Jeremy I think's done a great
job of settling uh the the issues
relating to that mini budget I want to
be here that the home office doing I
think one of the most important roles in
government and making sure that people
feel secure and protected